also new at 4 the southern nevada health
district releasing new numbers
on breakthrough cases those are cases
contracted after someone receives a
vaccine
the health district reporting a total of
70 break of 70 breakthrough
hospitalizations and 11 breakthrough
deaths right here in clark county
kate houston spoke to a local testing
company about the increase in patients
as well as one man's experience with the
virus even after getting the vaccine
kate
yes a christian health officials say the
delta variant is 60 times more
contagious than the uk variant and it's
continuing to spread
this is why wearing a mask and trying to
social distance are all still good
practices when in large groups
or around strangers e-7 health offers
various covenanting testing options
lately a majority of their tests are for
those traveling internationally
but ceo dr jonathan bakhtari says
they've seen an uptick in testing for
younger people
a group the cdc says is less likely to
get the vaccine
he's urging everyone to get their shots
saying it will give you milder symptoms
if you do contract the virus
this was the case for peter geraldi who
received his vaccine in march
but tested positive less than a week ago
durali thinks he got it from a recent
golden knights game
he says if he could change one thing he
wished he would have worn
a mask and it's hard there's a lot of
there's there's peer pressure you know
people are well what are you wearing a
mask for you know but it's really
i don't know my experience is it's the
right thing to do
drawlee said his symptoms started as a
cold but quickly developed to a fever
loss of taste and smell and fatigue
while he's still having some symptoms
he is starting to feel better his wife
marianne is also vaccinated
but did not get coveted and as case
numbers in clark county rise dr bhaktari
is highly recommending that people
continue to get tested
to prevent even more spread of this
virus back to you